[Musica]
parlare di evoluzione e cercare di farlo
in modo diciamo così colorito in modo un
po' vivace non è così facile ma ci
provo per
nel ragionamento
parto prendendo l'enciclopedia tre cani
che come chiunque ho sulla mia scrivania
e vado a leggere la definizione del
termine
evoluzione evoluzione È un processo di
trasformazione continuo per cui una data
realtà passa da uno stato ad uno
successivo quest'ultimo
peraltro normalmente più diciamo così
perfezionato
attraverso una serie di cambiamenti
successivi Ecco che il termine
cambiamento È un termine
chiave il cambiamento È un qualcosa per
il quale l'essere umano non è
predisposto Il cambiamento implica un
dispendio di energie un dispendio di
tempo e perché no implica anche in
qualche modo saper affrontare
l'incognito qualcosa che non conosciamo
noi conosciamo la realtà attuale non
quella che
verrà quindi l'essere umano è
predisposto a tutelare diciamo così lo
status quo però al tempo stesso ognuno
di noi ha esperienza del fatto che il
cambiamento è una parte imprescindibile
della realtà che ci circonda della vita
che viviamo tutti i
giorni quindi qualcuno uno direbbe la
domanda sorge
spontanea quindi è essenziale capire
come affrontare il cambiamento e
esistono fondamentalmente due modi
Questo è il
primo stare fermi non fare nulla
aspettare che il cambiamento ci
raggiunga e ahimè in questo caso il più
delle volte ci
travolga Quindi direi che eviterei di
consigliarlo il secondo metodo invece è
quello di cercare di anticiparlo
anticipare il cambiamento Cosa significa
anticipare il
cambiamento significa fare qualcosa
prima che il cambiamento
arrivi affinché noi siamo già pronti al
passo coi tempi direi nel momento in cui
il cambiamento ci avrà
raggiunto Ecco che a questo punto la
parte razionale del mio del mio cervello
finalmente va in panchina e lascia
lascia il campo alla parte un pochettino
più
creativa che mi
suggerisce Questa immagine per me il
concetto di
evoluzione significa è stare sulla
cresta
dell'onda stare sulla cresta dell'onda
significa essere aggiornato con i tempi
Ora io non so quanti di voi in questa
aula abbiano esperienza di surf Io ne ho
pochina ma a sufficienza per
capire che non si tratta il surf non è
unicamente tecnica e capacità di stare
diciamo così in
equilibrio c'è una fase iniziale che è
altrettanto importante se non la più
importante immaginate di vedere il
surfista che è in mare aperto a
cavalcioni sulla sua tavola da Surf e
sta scrutando l'orizzonte sta scrutando
appunto il mare aperto Cosa sta facendo
in questo momento il
surfista sta
semplicemente attendendo di individuare
la sua onda quella che lui deciderà di
cavalcare quella nella quale riporre
tutte le sue aspettative per una bella
cavalcata e chiaramente lo farà in base
alle sue diciamo così capacità e in base
a anche le dimensioni dell'onda che sta
arrivando allo stesso modo a inizio anni
50 a Maranello un giovane carrozziere di
Maranello Umberto
Zanasi decise che la sua
onda era quella di lavorare per quel
marchio automobilistico che diventerà il
marchio automobilistico più famoso al
mondo
e
questa decisione non è poi così facile
da prendere perché comunque ci vorrà
tanta
pazienza la prima carrozzeria sarà
aperta a inizio anni 50 l'autorizzazione
la carrozzeria autorizzata arriverà dopo
circa 15
anni ora il sorfista Ha individuato la
sua onda ha deciso che è quella
esattamente l'onda che vuole andare a
prendere quella l'onda che vuole
deve
prepararsi quindi cosa fa si gira di
180° questa volta guarderà verso la
spiaggia verso la terra ferma si
corica sulla sua tavola e nell'esatto
momento in cui percepisce che la Risacca
del mare lo sta tirando un pochettino
indietro a quel punto inizia a remare
aare forte con le braccia proprio così
il più forte possibile e lo fa perché
deve prendere un po' di velocità a cosa
serve questa
velocità serve per evitare di
essere travolto dall'onda e al tempo
stesso serve perché affinché la tavola
riesca Come si suol dire a prendere
l'onda e quindi poi a permettergli di
alzarsi e Se questo sorfista fosse
un'azienda come fa un'azienda a Rem a
prendere
velocità molto semplice lo fa facendo
investimenti che devono essere fatti
chiaramente al momento giusto quindi
prima che il cambiamento
arrivi investimenti in termini di in
primis persone perché le aziende sono
fatte di persone in questa avventura
iniziano in
quattro oggi contiamo più di 350
dipendenti investimenti in termini di
strutture la prima officina la prima
carrozzeria di Umberto Zanasi
Probabilmente qualcuno di voi qui
presente lo sa Eda esattamente qui
dietro in questo in questo vicolo qui
dietro e si narra la leggenda narra che
fosse talmente angusto l'ingresso che le
vetture Sì magari per entrare non era
poi così complicato perché tanto le
macchine erano già un po' acciaccata
dovevano essere sistemate ma per uscire
Bisogna stare molto molto attenti per
evitare di
graffiarli oggi contiamo nove
sedi per
circa più di 35.000 m qu
coperti investimenti in termini di
processi l'azienda deve rimanere al
passo con i tempi le esigenze del
mercato le aspettative dei clienti
crescono e bisogna rimanere al passo coi
tempi Ed ecco che gli investimenti in
termini di processi e di tecnologie sono
essenziali come Nel nostro caso la
realizzazione di un impianto
robotizzato di
verniciatura torniamo un attimino però
al nostro amico sorfista al mare
aperto ora il sorfista in piedi sulla
sua tavola Ha preso l'onda sta sorf cioè
è emozionantissimo perché sfare stare in
piedi sulla propria tavola
significa sentire che è la padronanza
riesce a dominare la natura riesce a
dominare il mare è un'emozione
bellissima ma è un equilibrio
estremamente difficile da mantenere non
è un equilibrio statico non bisogna
stare fermi Così immobili altrimenti si
cade è un equilibrio dinamico il
sorfista sposterà il peso col proprio
corpo avanti o indietro rispetto alla
tavola a seconda se la tavola sta
andando troppo lenta o troppo forte
rispetto
all'onda allo stesso modo un'azienda
benché con un business magari
consolidato benché con un business in
crescita costante a livello di fatturato
di profittabilità
con una clientela consolidata non può
rimanere immobile deve sempre essere
aggiornata con i
tempi oggi come oggi il tema della
sostenibilità è un tema essenziale
nessuna azienda Al di là delle
dimensioni che abbia non può farne meno
e quindi ecco che per qualsiasi azienda
è
essenziale investire tempo energia
denaro
risorse per ridurre gli sprechi per
iniziare a calcolare la propria Carbon
foodprint per capire poi come poterla
ridurre per approvvigionarsi
di risorse energetiche rinnovabili
insomma in poche parole per diminuire
l'impatto ambientale
Questo è un tema che fino a qualche anno
fa non è che fosse così
irrilevante ogni azienda deve rispettare
e diciamo così replicare anche la
società in cui è immersa Ecco che il
tema della multietnicità Anche questo è
un tema
essenziale oggi un'azienda deve avere la
capacità di
abbracciare personale che arrivi da Zone
geografiche diverse che abbia estrazioni
culturali
diverse Cyber Security questo termine
che sembrerebbe il titolo di una
narrativa fantascientifica e che anche
questo fino a qualche anno fa non
esisteva Oggi è un tema essenziale gli
attacchi hacker possono capitare in
qualsiasi momento e possono creare dei
danni inestimabili all'azienda possono
coprire il personale i clienti for
anche in questo caso è un tema che
l'azienda deve affrontare deve capire
che è un problema Deve capire che va
affrontato e va
gestito Ed ecco che il surfista ha
ultimato la sua surfata è arrivato sulla
spiaggia e cosa
fa non sta fermo un secondo prende
subito la sua tavola sottobraccio si
gira di 0° e Riparte verso il mare
aperto riparte alla
ricerca di nuove sfide di una nuova Onda
da
cavalcare allo stesso
modo
noi non possiamo mai
fermarsi noi dobbiamo mantenere quello
stimolo Quella curiosità quella
volontà di guardarci attorno studiare la
realtà in cui viviamo capire quali sono
i cambiamenti
che stanno avvenendo che
avverranno e
anticiparli questo continuo
esercizio è un esercizio che ci
permetterà non
solo di migliorare la nostra capacità di
cavalcare l'onda che già conosciamo ma
cosa più importante ci permetterà di
poter affrontare delle sfide che oggi
non immaginiamo nemmeno che esistano
come qualche anno fa Non immaginavamo
cosa potesse significare Cyber
Security Questo esercizio continuo e
costante ci
permetterà di surfare quell'onda che
oggi ancora non vediamo perché è troppo
lontana non ce la possiamo nemmeno
immaginare Ma ci permetterà di sfare
quell'onda perché l'onda più
l'onda più bella quella che ci darà più
soddisfazione è quella che deve ancora
arrivare
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Grazie